حشود غير مسبوقه وصلت الى مطار الخرطوم
لاستقبال زعيم الحزب الاتحادي الديمقراطي
الاصل ومرشد الطريقه الختميه محمد عثمان
المرغني
عوده الميرغني تاتي في توقيت سياسيين بالغ
التعقيد اذا يشهد حزبه بل هو بيته كثير من
الانقسامات ويشهد الوطن حاله من التصدي
والتباعد السياسي امال عريضه يحملها هؤلاء
المواطنون الذين جاءوا من كل حد وصوب
لاستقبال زعيمهم التاريخي والديني
هو الخير هو البركه
[موسيقى]
مولانا تعني عوده الامن والامان
والاستقرار باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى لهذا
الوطن اللي كان مخطف شويه لكن في الوقت
المناسب وان شاء الله يعني كل لما الشمس
لكل الشعب السوداني
برغم ان الميرغني القادم للوفاق بطبيعه
الحال بدات لحظه وصوله بتفجير خلاف جديد
حينما رفض نزول من الطائره بحجه ان ابنه
الحسن في استقباله عناصر من امن المطار
ابلغ الحسن بطلب والده والذي سارع بالخروج
من المطار ورغم هذه البدايه الا ان الحزب
الاتحادي يعمل فيها الحاله الخلافات
وتوسيع دائره المشاوره
دائره التشاور حول المطلوبات المخففه
السريعه والحلول انتاج حلول قبل التطبيق
في الفتره الانتقاليه بعيدا عن الداخل
الاتحادي قريبا من التحالفات والكيانه
الجديده تعول بعض القوى السياسيه على عوده
الميرغني في لم الشمل وتقري بشقه
الخلافته ظل يركز على مسائل بالنسبه لنا
اساسيه رفضه للتدخل الاجنبي
ورفضه لتعدد الجيوش
ودعوته المتكرره لحوار سودان السوداني
وماذا سيقول وكيف سيؤثر على المشهد
السياسي اسئله يطرحها الشارع والقوه
السياسيه الاخرى غير ان عودته بعد غياب
قارب العشر سنوات سيؤثر على مجريات المشهد
السياسي المليء بالتجاذبتي والاستغطابات
لينا يعقوب العربيه الخرطوم